[Musique]
le nom indique qu'il établit une
domination totale sur l'éléphanteau, un mélange
de punitions retenues mais aussi de certaines
récompenses, cela entraîne des dommages physiques et
psychologiques, mais le but est de
faire comprendre à l'éléphant que
désobéir aux gens est douloureux.
[Musique]
c'est l'industrie du voyage et le
gouvernement qui doivent mettre un terme à
cela. Nous devons donc nous assurer qu'il s'agit de la
dernière génération d'éléphants utilisée pour le
tourisme commercial en captivité, par
exemple en promouvant davantage un
tourisme basé uniquement sur l'observation où ce
le risque d'interaction directe est supprimé de l'
équation
[Musique]
l'ours vanille viens à moi la nature
conquise ou la double capitale o l'équipement du monde proche
il n'y a pas de zones où l'
éléphant peut se déplacer et être élevé pour se nourrir donc
beaucoup de garçons doivent encore voyager
pour parcourir de longues distances et trouver de la nourriture
à partir d'une source extérieure et c'est très
difficile, beaucoup d'entre eux s'enfuient de là
[Musique]
une charge élevée que certains éléphants
font perdre la nuit et se promènent dans les
zones agricoles des propriétés agricoles et
cela  probablement commencer ce que nous appelons
Hesh facile conflit homme-éléphant
[Musique]